el problema nos dice determinar cuáles
de los siguientes números son primos
cuáles son compuestos y cuáles no son
primos ni compuestos ok ese problema es
un repaso de todo lo que hemos visto
porque vamos a acordarnos de que
significa que tengamos un número primo
vamos a ponerlo aquí un número primo un
número primo es un número natural como
el 1 2 3 4 5 etcétera pero que cumple
una propiedad muy importante que
solamente tiene dos factores un número
primo solamente tiene dos factores dos
factores y sus factores son el mismo y
la unidad entonces sus dos factores es
la unidad es decir el uno y el mismo
mismo ok me podrías dar un ejemplo de un
número primo pues bueno uno que se me
ocurre es el número tres el número tres
solamente se puede formar como
multiplicación de dos números naturales
multiplicando al uno por tres es la
única forma de formar al tres con dos
números naturales y por lo tanto sus
únicos dos factores es uno y el mismo y
entonces podemos decir que el 3 es un
número primo es un número primo ok que
es un número compuesto
bueno pues seguimos recordando cuáles
son los números compuestos entonces voy
a decir que un número compuesto
compuesto es aquel que tiene más de dos
factores más de dos factores más
de dos factores también es un número
natural pero este número es un número
especial porque tiene más de dos
factores le podrías dar un ejemplo bueno
se me ocurre no sé el 8 el 8 tiene como
factores al 1 tiene como factor al 2
tiene como factor al 4 y también tiene
como factor al 8 por lo tanto el 8 tiene
muchos factores y como tienen más de dos
factores entonces es un número compuesto
y cuáles no son primos ni compuestos
bueno es que tiene un tramposo en este
vídeo pero vámonos con calma vamos a
pensar primero en el 24 el 24 quiénes
son los factores de 24 bueno los
primeros que se me ocurren es 1 y 24 124
son factores de 24 ok tendrá otros más
pensemos 24 tiene mitad claro 24 tiene
mitad y la mitad de 24 es 12 por lo
tanto 2 también es un factor de 24 2
divide a 24 y nos da
exacto existirá algún otro bueno justo
en este momento es cuando ya puedes
decir que el 24 es un número compuesto
ya podríamos contestar el 24 es
compuesto porque tienen más de dos
factores ahora aunque ya encontramos más
de dos factores déjame terminar de ver
cuáles son los demás factores de 24
porque se me ocurre que 24 también tiene
tercera por ejemplo 3 y 3 por 8 es 24
entonces sí divido al 24 entre 3 me da 8
y tendrá otros más si también tiene al
46 por 4 es 24 por lo tanto también
tiene el 4 y también tienen 6 es decir
que el 24 tiene un montón de factores
muchos más de 2 y entonces ahora sí
podemos concluir que el 24 es un número
compuesto lo voy a poner aquí este es un
número compuesto ok ya tenemos la
respuesta de uno de estos ejercicios y
el 2 que va a pasar con el 2
bueno pensemos un poco en el 2 el 2
solamente se puede escribir como 1 por
2-1 a divide el 2
ok el 2 también divide el 2
pero no existe ningún otro número
natural entre el 1 y el 2 por lo tanto
sus únicos dos factores es 1 y 2 y como
solamente tiene dos factores el mismo y
la unidad entonces podemos decir que el
2 es un número primo es un número primo
pero además de ser un número primo es un
número primo muy especial porque es el
único número primo par que existe como
el 2
es el único único primo
porque existe para que existe y esto es
porque cualquier otro número que sea par
y déjame ponerlo aquí en cualquier otro
número que sea par por definición de
número par va a ser divisible entre 2 es
decir que todos va a estar entre sus
factores cualquier otro para cualquier
otro par no va a ser un número primo
es un
número
primo primo de hecho el único primo par
es 2 todos los demás no son primos o
nuevos compuestos muy bien ahora es el
turno del 1 veamos qué es lo que pasa
con el 1 el 1 tiene en primer lugar a la
unidad como uno de sus factores y en
otro lugar tiene a sí mismo como uno de
sus factores pero que cree es el mismo
es la unidad el uno es bastante tramposo
porque solamente tiene un factor el
único factor es sí mismo o la unidad
porque la unidad y sí mismo es lo mismo
entonces el 1 es un número tramposo es
un número que solamente tiene un factor
sólo un factor sólo un factor factor
y su único factor es el mismo por lo
tanto como no tiene dos factores
solamente tiene un factor y no tiene más
de dos factores el 1 es un número
tramposo el 1 es un número que no es
primo y no es compuesto entonces este es
el único número que es tramposo el único
número natural que no es primo no es
primo ni tampoco es compuesto no es
compuesto con puesto
el número 1 es un número especial y un
poco raro y ahora pensemos en el 17
bueno pues el 17 si tú te acuerdas un
poco de tus criterios de divisibilidad
el 17 no es divisible entre 2 de entre 3
ni entre 4 y entre 5 entre 6 entre 7
entre 89 y entre 11 y 12 y 13 y 14 mil
15 y 16 ninguno de todos ellos divide al
17 por lo tanto los únicos factores de
17 es 1 y 17 porque ningún otro número
los dividen eso quiere decir que el 17
solamente tiene dos factores el 1 y el
17 y por lo tanto es un número primo es
un número primo y ya está ya puede
clasificar a todos estos números que
tenían un principio y es todo por este
vídeo